[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back
to the break room uh and welcome back to
a break room break room after
yesterday's a little sojourn into the
last of us uh thank you uh Brandon
Jessica and Anna for that wonderful
after show but we're back here to talk
about the nerdy nose you need the nerdy
news you need to know
um today we're going to talk we are
going to talk just a little bit about
last of us but we're gonna get into Adam
Warlock some new Ant-Man images and we
might even do some roasting some roasts
I I don't know um with me to do all of
that we've got Brandon Barrick Jessica
Clemons Tommy bechtold I'm Jack
Huddleston we're all thrilled to be here
um
Tommy especially look at that
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed uh I just
woke up 18 fresh hours of sleep last
night
thanks to leave Pia two cast members had
a weekend okay the other two cast
members I mean just had a couple days
off there were two cast members had a
weekend see if you could figure it out
that's right
um uh it was a great weekend and then we
had Monday which we all love Mondays but
it came with uh we have that Mandalorian
trailer which was really nice uh more
about that later but uh they also
tickets went on sale for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania they give out a little
teaser another little additional small
mini trailer with some new stuff
um uh which is exciting and now you know
we know this movie obviously we're gonna
be diving into the quantum realm it's
Quantum media folks uh but we're still
no wonder around here like how we're
gonna get back out right because you
can't end this movie with everyone stuck
there that's not a fun ending uh and one
of the new teasers we got there there
was a new line of dialogue that was a
little different this was the teaser for
the 3D release uh we hear Kang say this
place isn't what you think it's a cage
and we can help each other oh it's a
cage a king cage if you will that makes
me think
this is just a little out there but the
concept of a cage is someone builds
something to keep something contained
right is there a larger entity than Kang
that like the quantum realm seems like
this like weird world that just exists
in a smaller molecular level
is there something larger out there that
is creating these Realms as prisons as
cages for people that we we haven't
thought about reminds me of the HBO The
Watchmen Series where Ozymandias got
sent uh not to spoil it but he got kind
of put in a cage by another character
it's slowly revealed yeah right and so
it's like like um yeah somebody more
powerful than him that's an interesting
way of thinking about it well we knew
another king right uh he remains he was
powerful enough to keep all the other
kings out yeah uh but maybe this was
like a cage like one of those raccoon
cages they put out there oh he got
himself stuck he got himself
real quick before we move on everybody
put what do you think did Ken get
himself caught in there did a power
greater than Kang put him there or did
another Kang put him there
uh the way he talked about it there it
does sound like I think it was like a
trap where this looked very the quiet
another Kang set it up so that this
Quantum realm looks so I want to be
there and he's in there and he's stuck
well if this is King the Conqueror
perhaps it was like this is a world you
must conquer it's so tempting look at
these people they're so tiny what do
they know who are they what are they
cooking I must conquer them and know all
their secrets
maybe a better more uh benevolent Kang
is like this is one of the worst
killings we've got to trap him right in
the quantum realm I still I also think
he's the dumbest King he's fell for the
trip
brother this King stinks he's still
smarter than a lot of people but when
compared to all the kings well and I'll
just throw out you know yeah you would
think again King's gonna be the big bad
for the MCU for for a while we know that
and so you would think anybody that
could trap him somewhere that he can't
get out of on his own must be extra
powerful but maybe not we've seen and
you're going to talk about this right
like circumstances can accidentally trap
you in the quantum realm right could
have been somebody much less powerful
than him than just acts you know got him
in there trapped him in there right I'll
just say that well yeah and as we look
at like how we think this film could end
or how they resolve the issue of getting
out of the quantum realm let's look at
the facts that we know because this
isn't Rogue Theory we're not just going
to spitball stuff here okay we're gonna
look at the facts folks all right when
dealing with the quantum role in the
past and other MCU films there's usually
been someone or something outside of the
quantum realm to help pull someone out
help bring them out okay working
backwards from the most recent Sky Lang
he's stuck in there during the blip or
the snap whatever you want to call it a
rat or a mouse it was a rat cross across
the controls of the quantum tunnel it
pulls them back out of it okay that's
how it happened there and end game uh
Hank and Janet all right and Ant-Man the
WASP they have a ship
then they have the quantum Channel they
go in and goes in with the ship he's got
the ship and he drives the ship back out
they got to make the building big so
that he can see it on the little radar
screen he's got the tunnel so he's got
the things he's got the ship helping him
get out and like uh the the tunnel the
quantum tunnel that they built in the
Pim Labs now in the first Ant-Man movie
Scott Lang he's fighting yellow jacket
or whatever he goes subatomic to like
destroy his machinery and he kind of
gets stuck in the quantum realm now that
Quantum realm looks very different right
it's like more of a black void he's
hearing things it's a little crazy they
later add in the second movie that
that's where Janet was able to like mind
meld with him in the quantum realm but
he's able to get himself out on his own
he pulls one of the little grow discs
the blue disc he puts it in his
regulator and he like hits it and he
gets out so he kind of does it on his
own in that one instance whether it's
Pim particles
that are the key to getting out he still
has technology to help him get out right
he's got the Pim particles and he
probably had something that Janet didn't
have when she was stuck down them for so
long because he had the grow disk like
on his body now if they get sucked in
this movie and they have the like pin
particles on them that could be
important we we assume that they're
traveling with pin particles at all
times right right you've got something
particles is the only way to reach the
quantum room that we know so far right
that's that's like the key so it's like
it makes sense like even just a little
bit of it yeah I don't know if the
quantum tunnel that they built if it has
Pim I assume there's some pimps
yeah that utilizes pin party I think the
pen particles are what gives you that
drive that makes it able to break that
layer into the quantum realm
um I'm also not Hank pin so I didn't
create these it's just the rules of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well yeah
here's one thing that I think could be
crazy is is this Scotland is six one six
six got Lang because of his he got
himself out of the quantum realm is he
special in some sort of way is he
different than all the others the only
person we've seen right because in
theory when Janet back in the 60s or
whatever initially got stuck in the
quantum realm when she went in there she
had pimtech that was how she was able to
get her shoot on right but she was not
able to get herself out right so like
yeah what is it about Scott that has
enabled him is it just that the Pim
technology has advanced to the point in
like you know
um Janet's Mark II wasp suit or whatever
wasn't capable of of getting itself out
yeah
maybe I don't know I don't think so do
you think it was just I it had to be in
the suit yeah because his her suit is
ancient and right yeah it's like 40
years she was there 30 years right or
something like that so it's like yeah I
think I mean that's the only excuse
because it's like Janet's also brilliant
right so she would be able to figure out
things upside down I know it's holding
my shirt together
enable pins more helpful than you
thought yeah
go ahead and call me out no maybe so
they can hold my face together because
I've been crying for 48 hours I know
well we did talk about well you
mentioned this earlier the idea that
maybe maybe there's not one way into the
realm in this movie maybe there's a
little in and out action going on yeah
the like press release they put out
described it as like a one-way trip for
this family into the quantum realm but I
think that that could be purposely
misleaded I mean just kind of sci-fi we
know the writer Jeff loving this is has
a reverence for other sci-fi fantasy and
comic book properties right like he's
definitely someone who is well versed in
the field
one of the classic tropes of these
things stranger things addresses at all
times there's always another way out
there's always a secret door there's
always a back door the hello there's
always uh you know uh another another
way that you just have to figure out
someone else figured out another way to
get out so I wonder if that's going to
be another thing too is where they
figure out there's whether it's like a
portal or someone else got 98 of the way
there and they now have the technology
to finish this and they can start
creating entrances and exits to the
quantum realm which opens it up for the
quantum realm being a setting in future
Marvel things right I mean because I
don't know that this is even though it's
quantumanium seems like it's the magnum
opus of the the Ant-Man and Quantum
realm as a concept doesn't feel like
they'll leave the quantum realm forever
and will never go back down right we've
talked a little bit on the show there's
good odds of this core cast right
somebody's probably gonna die yeah
somebody might choose to stay in the
quantum realm and not want to come back
out two people might choose that a
couple people a specific couple yeah and
then some Cassie's not going to stay in
the corner can we assume she's got to
come out and live her life maybe do some
Young Avengers types I think she is he's
probably gonna get on Tick Tock and
start doing lip sync yeah I think so too
I do want to ask you about what's going
to happen in the quantum realm but real
fast uh we got a Super Chat uh thanks
all our Super Chat are sending in stuff
fly ninja 808 was asking do you think
there are different levels to the
quantum realm like the one Scott almost
got stuck in during the first movie
that's a good point because like they
have said in the press release that uh
this is the deepest level of the quantum
room we've ever seen before and in the
trailer we see a shot where Scott looks
like he's shrinking down to go into that
yellow sure squid eye thing no I I also
I this is important fly ninja are you a
ninja that can fly or are you a really
cool ninja call us if you know
oh also 808 is that an area code or is
that a drum machine oh
because we know 818 is until we die we
have to assume there's no floor right
enjoy it yeah
because that yeah what Scott goes to in
the first movie it's it's not what we
see represented in the second and any
other time we've seen the quantum realm
it's just a black void it was like the
dire warning that Hank gave him when he
first explained this like Atomic
traveling of going up and down is like
you can go too far down well and I
wonder if he went past the quantum realm
and Janet maybe helped pull him back a
little bit which helped him get back out
because if she's connecting with him
there uh I wonder if you did go past it
and maybe that's what also makes him
special uh is is he's got he went there
if it changes his DNA a little bit he's
got the juice but he's just like he's
he's statistically significant amongst
the the infinite number of Scott Langs
this one is an anomaly he's the one
matrixy okay so if the quantum is a cage
How do they how do how do they get out
of here just someone help them from the
outside uh I I've said I said this
before but like it looks like in the
trailer at one point Cassie Lang is
outside of the quantum realm again she's
in the laboratory looking at that yellow
thing you think that might be later in
this I think it's later I don't think
that's the initial like suck in or it's
a different casting I'm sorry initial
second it's the official name of it now
let me miss a second and someone who
just spent 36 hours in a cage in Vegas
mistress Vanessa there's three ways out
of a cage you got to get greased up and
slide okay through the bars oh that's
one way the other way
the Third Way Brute Force baby oh
I do like that so you think now that we
know again
Cassie does she is involved in the
initials
somehow but if you think later in the
movie She's out and helps pull her
family out well how does she get out
that's what I want to know uh well I we
were talking before we started rolling
here there's a couple frequent Ant-Man
cast members that are not featured in
the trailer uh that being uh Bobby
Cannavale right uh that being Randall
Parks yeah a Jimmy woo character that
being Judy Grant Judy Greers uh ex-wife
character right like could one of them
in a um you know oh I'm just stopping by
I haven't heard from you in two days oh
knock knock nobody's in here oh what's
this button do kind of an accidental how
about Greg turkington yeah yeah the
manager of the Baskin-Robbins put him
back in there yeah
um well do you think I guess that that
that speaks to like we don't know who or
I mean is this is sword involved is you
know is whoever's running the Avengers
figures this out because at this point
now Pim Tech in in Scotland are so high
profile he's doing all this press at the
beginning there's no way government
agencies aren't getting getting in on
this Quantum game themselves because we
know Val's out there trying to track
down all the vibranium oh you think
she's not trying to track down all the
pen particles they've spent decades
trying to make super soldiers theorem
you know they're working on their own
pimp Town that's the interesting part is
because of Hawkeye we see these uh the
Pim Tech the arrows yeah that are just
being left behind so it's like it's not
that hard to actually get a hold of the
things and study it but I think because
the quantum realm is so hard to
understand and reach only Hank Pym and
uh uh what's his name Lawrence
Fishburne's character uh sort of Goliath
Bill Russell sort of no NBA legend
sort of know how to tackle it and I
don't know if it's going to be an
accidental button Champion sorry I don't
know if it's gonna be an accidental
button since we've already gotten the
rat going over it it is a fun call back
nonetheless I think they're just gonna
have to get themselves out yeah and just
the suits alone being down there might
be the Pim Tech enough needed I really
agree and that's a great Point Jessica
that like we've already seen The
Accidental get out a couple times and it
gives these characters more agency if
one of them is able to figure yeah and
it's not just random or circumstance now
it does speak to what could be different
about this movie it's not an external
force it is what Kang wants out of Scott
is Scott holds the key to an internal
Force being able to open up like a
two-way tunnel you know like that people
are able to escape the quantum realm
from inside without somebody on the
outside doing everything and The
Accidental get out is what you got to do
if the initial second doesn't work
on an accidental get out pretty much
sure we're running the the initials
I love these ideas but they're all wrong
here's what's going to happen okay he
just describes it as a cage I think that
line is is like second act King where
he's like that's the initial thing he's
tricking he's got to do something it's
not really a cage uh but if it is a cage
you gotta destroy a cage okay and one
thing that the 616 MCU loves to do is
destroy things they've destroyed the
Infinity Stones yep they've destroyed
the Dark Hall the book of Ashanti
they've destroyed right whole round are
you saying destroy the quantum they're
gonna destroy the quantity whoa and like
this is gonna lead to like in incursions
and and like Secret Wars and all that
battle World stuff is because like the
616 has to be stopped it's out of its
mind it's it's killing celestials it's
destroying it's famous I think the other
universe is gonna be like we've got to
stop the 616. this is it out of control
this is a crazy Theory but I love it
because they destroyed the quantum
because also doesn't that set up
potentially King as like a good guy to
the people of the quantum realm he's
trying to protect the quantum Realm by
stopping 616. I don't think it's gonna
happen but it is a fun period I think I
think there's going to be some real
change and speaking of real change I
want to ask the Marriott to lift my band
for my initial suck in I was a boy the
jacuzzi was too tempting I get it now
it's only for soaking not for sucking
let me back Marriott let me back into
your hotel I'm using this platform I
want your breakfast I want your swimming
pools
the second is another place you can stay
that's not America oh by the way yeah if
you're ever in Burbank California which
we're very far away from do not stay at
the suck in okay because some say it
blows
Jameson said in this great Super Chat uh
pointing out how much real world or
asking how much real world time will
pass if the entire movie takes place in
the quantum realm and like if going sub
Quantum means even more real world time
passing kind of like Inception where
like if you go deeper times moving
faster or whatever
this could be a great way for them to
Jump Ahead in time if they want to well
no and it's been a little confusing
right because like obviously the quantum
realm can be used for time travel right
how they use it yeah uh aging is a
little wonky yeah like Scott doesn't age
but like seemingly it's like everybody
was aging on the outside right like I
mean looks great don't get me wrong
maybe the age like somebody her age
who's had some work done I don't know
but um uh save it for the later segments
no no no no no but I'm just saying like
if we're following the logic of of how
time passes in the quantum realm it
hasn't fully been established is that
right or has it yeah we don't know they
just they they have the great uh
explanation line time works differently
so who knows I don't know we we may uh
Sue discover that Janet was like no I
was here for like 100 years like in
front of time and I did a lot here yeah
and maybe time passes faster but you age
slower yeah maybe well we also have like
Scott being pushed through time or time
was pushed through Scotland by Bruce
Banner and he aged and you know changed
different like that like she may have
looked it may have not been that long
but she touched a Time streaming it was
interesting it
yeah I could add uh the we still have
Modoc who is seemingly changed
completely wow yeah and he's been in
there for a shorter amount of time maybe
maybe he chose to look like that maybe
yeah
well Hector Rivera was asking if they if
we think our our family here is going to
join forces with a villain in the
quantum realm to beat Kang maybe Modoc
secretly Hanks King I mean modak
definitely hates Canada he definitely
hates cake well but he definitely needs
Scott Lane whoa yeah yeah he's got a lot
he's got his face he hates laying in
King his face in the trailer when he's
Corey stall's face he just looks so
miserable it's like he's like
that's him
well I mean and there's a lot of we're
going to meet a lot of quantum
characters that some of which will be on
the side of our uh Buddies the Ant-Man
family and some of which won't right
um uh William Jackson Harper's character
uh some of these other like Rebel
Alliance kind of gentura gentora uh Bill
Murray from Crandall or whatever his
name is Crim Crandall the biscuit Lord
Kyler I think it's Lord
yeah krylar cry more oh Krylon great
great screen
um
[Music]
Tommy shut up
real quick final verdict do you think
whoever eventually gets
um you know after the initial second
there's the final suck out
who who initiates the final suck out is
it somebody internally maybe Scott
unlocking a secret thing it's usually
the woman it's one final suck out and
then we never speak again uh I think I
I'm saying Hank and Janet don't leave
they stay behind me I think so but of
their own choosing yeah yeah well Janet
wants to stay and then Hank's like oh
I'll stay too yes I could see this my
hips are terrible I can't do it I'm so
much more flexible in the quantum so
much lighter the I can see this I could
see perhaps Kang and Modoc escaping with
Cassie like taking her kidnapping her
back and then Hank and hope and Scott
and Janet figuring out that they can get
two more of them out or something like
that we've got two ways out so so we
also got a fox a chicken yes and a cow
but you can't leave the fox and the
chicken in the boat at the same time
that's right but you can
get a great look at a T-bone steak by
sticking your head up with another skin
all right no I think I think in the end
Hank Hank and Janet will kind of
sacrifice them the chances of them
getting back to the regular world to
send uh to send hope and Scott back to
to Saint Cassie's and the final battle
will take place
and Earth with a good Cassie back I like
that I might twist that it does feel
like some of the energy in the trailer
is setting up Scott might be the one
sacrificing himself for somebody else
right like I don't have to win we just
both have to lose you think the trailer
is a fake out yeah you think Scott lives
he's got lives
uh agree to disagree
um oh I also real quick sorry before we
move on we did get some closure on fly
ninja he is a cool ninja 808 is the area
code for Hawaii whoa aloha means hello
and goodbye fly ninja uh thank you very
much
that's nice uh let's pivot here to some
headlines
uh great and thank you real quick to
Boogie's World Jalen Dorsett endless mic
1337 uh Mrs Tony Stark everybody's
sending in um Matthew Eagle I see that
you've changed your name back but I'll
never forget you Evan Corey you can't
Julie what will maybe come back and read
some of your uh super chats but thank
you for saying
lose was just too much to handle
a lot of the other YouTube channels were
like I don't know why this person keeps
super chatting US ah okay uh quick uh
some rundown of some headlines the big
news uh HBO is The Last of Us which we
loved and are excited about covering on
the channel uh the ratings came out it
premiered Sunday night with 4.7 million
viewers and that's uh the Network's
second largest series premiere Ever
After House of the Dragon which to be
fair did drop out twice that many but
still it's a big Premiere it's a holiday
weekend too yeah I don't think everyone
watched it uh Sunday night
um in in honor of MLK day they didn't
watch it I think they were they were
partying people traveling maybe yeah all
those parties not a normal but it may be
an honor maybe yeah but I mean and we're
hoping even as Word of Mouth spreads
because it's really good show like even
more people might go back and watch a
little later yeah
um as we mentioned earlier a new trailer
for season three of the Mandalorian came
out last night during the football game
yeah uh we got a new look at the plural
mandalorians uh din jarin's uh new
Navigator Droid a shot of either what we
think might be Coruscant or the city
planet from Kenobi uh confirmation of a
return to Tatooine
got to get to Tatooine baby
in what seems like a flashback to the
Jedi Temple during order 66.
when we see those lightsabers oh I'm
hyped baby
we got some more belly Moto in our lives
screaming May the force be with you we
talked about the staff meeting but I
think that confirms she banged a Jedi
yeah absolutely that's what she asked
him too yeah yeah May the force be with
you I'm getting sick of this noodling oh
my God
that's why Qui-Gon was so angry because
he was out there banging that's right
here's what they're bringing it was yeah
okay yeah okay I've got it on
uh in an interview with variety Julia
louis-dreyvis uh said she really really
wants to fight and you have coming
Thunderbolts movie fun uh she went on to
say she hasn't seen the script yet
there's so much secrecy around it
Thunderbolts begins filming in June of
this year and is slated uh to release on
July 26th of next year you know it would
be a fun little Easter egg in the
Thunderbolts as if they all made the bet
with each other from Seinfeld all the
Thunderbolts last one to you know I'm
just mad they didn't have like her and
Everett Ross like get into like a
domestic dispute or something just like
start beating each other they had that
kitchen scene together they started
swinging pots and pans or something yeah
they're both trained government
officials Nick it's kind of a domestic
assault it's a little touchy there
because they were in a couple yeah a
little touchy but if it's her fighting a
a Hydra agent or something like that oh
that's okay that guy's got a family but
not but then
those kids are hydrant too
you cut his head off four more kids
coming up wow uh James again told Empire
that Adam wardlock Adam Warlock is
definitely not a good guy while talking
about the powerful Cosmic entity he says
what we're seeing is the infant form of
warlock he's basically a baby
what a muscle baby
uh of course he's gonna be played by
Will Poulter uh who has a child within
We're the Millers
the script's getting stronger yeah
also in the um what was the Choose Your
Own Adventure Black Mirror oh yes uh
balder games
he's really good in that he's a talented
actor who got jacked uh but of course
but according to Gunn uh people online
were saying oh Tom Cruise should be out
of more luck yeah but he wanted a more
youthful actor Joseph speaks to like hey
you like getting these actors young yeah
they they could be around for five six
movies because we're gonna see a whole
lot of out of Warlock
absolutely absolutely he's a baby right
now and then he's gonna come into it at
the end and be like yeah and then he's
gonna realize once he's with the other
eternals in this guy and they're going
to teach him like as a cosmic entity
like the Marvels maybe
eternals too yeah
spinning around on Earth too much I
think that there's going to oh I'm so
sorry Jessica no I'll cut you off I
think that they are going to make a not
a Guardians 4. I think they will start a
new franchise kind of in that guardian's
world that might just be called like
guardians or something like that that'll
be maybe some of the characters that we
were introduced to before that were like
with the ravagers or or the other groups
that were like calling when they were
all all the cameos the fun candies at
the end of the last movie I just think
that they're gonna you gotta keep that
you have to keep space as a playground
for these characters and and and movies
and filmmakers so too big for her yeah
he'd rip through Earth so conclude I'm
sorry but I would say conclude the
Guardians of the Galaxy James Gunn
version and and then don't reboot it
just play in that world that's been
created if any of those Guardians actors
want to come back have them come back
within reason and then bring us make new
Guardians have new new team-ups well
it's a good point like if a lot of the
the titles we know in Phase five and
phase six there's not a lot of outer
space stuff yeah going on right like
Thunderbolts I mean we don't know what
what form King Dynasty and thank you
John uh secret Invasion will hopefully
have elements of it but it's what it's
going to be there's not a lot of outer
space there though coming up phase six
we don't know where Fantastic Four is
taking place that's right right uh we
can probably assume Deadpool's on Earth
probably blades on Earth I think Blade's
gonna be on Mars
blades are from Mars eternals Are from
Venus
condominia and friend of Tommy Bechtel
Jeff levnes uh described the new Ant-Man
as jodorowski's dune within Marvel Now
jodorowski's Dune is a pretty arcane
reference for film Geeks and people that
love Dune like myself uh Alexandra
Alexandro
[Applause]
Alejandro thank you jodorowski uh was a
a weirdo RDA director who almost made a
dune movie back in the 70s you can look
at there's a good documentary made about
it uh but crazy Arty weird uh maybe a
little bit more authentic to the
original novelization so like kind of
that's their way of saying like this is
a weird trippy
crazy world right that's going to have
crazy visuals and lots of weird stuff
going on
um Joe doraski's dude was an attempt by
Cult director okay it was written here
in the prompter guys I didn't need to go
dunk on uh with his own knowledge uh but
uh loveness described the quantum realm
as a limitless place of creation and
diversity and alien life Limitless
Cooper Cameo take one pill
um again exciting I think like as maybe
Jessica said earlier like we can keep
coming back to the quantum room
hopefully we do now hopefully this is
just like introduces us to these
different cultures and people and races
and species and whatever and they're
people that we want to keep visiting
right uh and speaking of quantumania we
got we got a first look at William
Jackson Harper's Quantum media character
there he is okay you know now that's a
quads if I've ever seen a quads yeah not
a lot you know just kind of like a
little bit of an outfit hairdo you know
uh that's just not wearing glasses oh
which makes them different he also looks
more to be on this like Rebellion side
of gentura and the Freedom Fighters than
like the Lord krylar yeah there's a
little less uh golden golden gems High
Society yeah he looks like he's working
alongside someone against them
yeah he also looks concerned doesn't he
when doesn't he yeah he's like
someone overcooked that roast beef oh
yeah that's what he looks like he's like
this chicken's gonna be dry
um we also got new images of both Kang
and Janet from that same Empire article
oh now we've been pointing out oh my God
the way quiet sitting all right I have a
couple thoughts about this photo okay
first off it's a chair right in front of
a bench but like to the point where you
can't sit on that bench right I I think
it's hard to see okay
guys floating and it moves because like
why put why put cushion on that bench if
it's not accessible that's right bring
up the image one more time just for me
oh God also the way that guy chose to
sit in my chair
his acting choices acting choices are
being made not sitting normally how the
chair is meant to function but choosing
draped to like it's like Louis the 16th
just like they very nice they sold that
chair in the 70s yeah uh from Neiman
Marcus you can buy it it would cost
fifteen thousand dollars and it was only
sold to cocaine dealers oh wow speaking
of Michelle Pfeiffer and her appearance
in uh Scarface yeah
um there she is that's a dope looking
photo look at that background I want
that in a black light poster
um yep very excited for all the visuals
all the sittings
you think is that the best sit we'll see
in quantumania it's like one of the top
four sets easily let's rank the sixth in
the MCU one of these days okay we'll do
who's got the is it a hot sit or is it a
dank [ __ ]
uh real quick we're gonna come back uh
the mandatory fund today
it's gonna be next level I just want to
tell you that I'm very excited for it
Tommy's got something cooked no not
cooking it is cooked it's cooked it is
roasted it is basted it is ready to
consume okay uh but uh real quick we
want to thank the folks that helped us
bring this episode to you all week and
that's our good friends at nordvpn we're
very excited we've wanted to do a movie
club on break room for a while where we
get to talk about maybe some of our
favorite films or things we don't
normally get to talk about and nordvpn
is helping us do that because
um one of the great gifts of using a VPN
is you get to tap into other streaming
services from other countries so without
needing to subscribe to a new service
you already subscribed to American
Netflix we know right oh you can change
your location using nordvpn to be from
other countries and access totally
different libraries of of Netflix and
they're still in English we confirmed
this earlier I was a little confused
because I hadn't tried this process we
confirmed you log into Japanese Netflix
you still get to watch movies in English
is to learn Japanese or anything like
that I did this to catch up on Better
Call Saul when it was like the most
recent season wasn't available
yes nordvpn has over 5000 servers in 60
different countries so it's potentially
up to 60 different Netflix libraries uh
if you're ever traveling abroad you know
maybe you're in Japan traveling Oh we
could still watch American stuff uh by
using a VPN uh reversing yeah you watch
eagles flying over mountains uh grains
fireworks trucks apple pies alligators
eating deer right out of the lake and
don't worry about bandwidth throttling
nor VPN gives you the best speed of any
VPN service so your content will be
streaming in that crisp high definition
so uh we here in the break room we're
all going to use nordvpn this week to
watch Knives Out yes there it is the
prequel to Glass Onion if you will the
first is Benoit Blanc uh mystery from
Ryan Johnson in the game so good
um it's not currently available on
American Netflix or any of the major
streaming services but we were going to
use it to watch it on Japanese Netflix
where it is streaming for free okay and
then on Friday we're going to spend some
time talking about our thoughts on
knives out so if you sign up for nordvpn
this week you can watch 90's out for
free too that's right and then come back
and listen to us and jump in the chat
and share your thoughts on Knives Out uh
so get nordvpn uh get your exclusive
nordvpn at nordvpn.com break room you'll
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift oh a bonus gift
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee so get it
for Movie Club I guarantee you'll like
it and you want to stick around but it's
risk-free that's end o r d
vpn.com break room we thank nordvpn for
sponsoring the show heck yeah
it's time for mandatory fun whoa
it's Tuesday and we didn't get to play
the graphic yesterday so play the
graphic again hey hey come on
come on
oh
yes it's Tuesday it's mandatory fun I'm
feeling so fine play that image of Janet
Van Dyke
uh I you know what I'd kill a lot of
drug dealers
uh just just spend some time with
Michelle anyway I'm here with my three
best friends in the whole world uh for a
little non-optional fun unfortunately
no none of us can be here too right all
four of us have to go I'm uh I have my
sentencing today and all and and the
rest of these guys are testifying
against me so we got to go uh everybody
leave everybody head on out and then uh
and then then you know um maybe we'll
slowly make our way back that's right
but back it's your boys and girls the
kings of roast comedy and queens of
roast comedy Ant-Man gave us a plethora
of new images this week and uh you know
while those other Jack offs they might
have liked it we hate it so we're gonna
roast these images and here we are the
clown Prince of Florida smack huddle hey
quadruple B Brandon the bad boy Barrack
that's 4B Jessica Clemens and me the
Jersey kid D psychobectal
now we've got the posters we are the
roasters let's see the images and let
the roasting begin yeah
huh
oh yeah sorry there were posters that
came out four of them from the movie
theaters and seven of character posters
that were released on the Twitter I
believe and we're gonna roast each image
yeah so the posters will be real oh
first of all
oh my God why is King hanging out in the
background like empty and the what we
got wrong video on YouTube
wait bring that poster back up okay yeah
I do like uh um the scale there poor
Cassie Lang what is she a booger in in
oops no
hey hey who's designing the guns at
Marvel you ought to use these guns for
for Peter shill oh get new guns Jesus
Christ make new guns oh what is this
King about to run a train look at all of
them lined up ready what is this uh what
are these uh Russian nesting dolls there
you go there you go
I got caught on the Kang train once it
sucked was that was that part of the
initial second that's right I got the
initial suck in from Jonathan majors and
let me tell you
there was nothing major about it whoa
another big league next post next poster
oh okay it looks like an anus
hey look at look at all those old people
there's enough gray hair in this poster
what is this 80 for Kenny oh what what
is this what is this Ant-Man and the
WASP cocooner Maniac hey what is this
what is this Inner Space Cowboys
what is this Honey I shrunk my prostate
using a prostate medication and now I
might not die what is this what is this
turtlenecks are in season because our
necks all look like raisins
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
what is this you know they say the
quantum realm as you go deeper down
reality can bend and that must explain
why they think we're dumb enough to
believe that in that reality Michael
Douglas and Michelle Pfeiffer on the
same height he's short and he lies about
his height folks
oh 3D okay real deep just want to say
how bad do they want to sell tickets
they're willing to fake a Spider-Man
logo
poster what is this real D does that
stand for real Dom I'm from New Jersey
what is this a poster for ants
well Jonathan Majors given blue steel up
there at the top of them so put the
poster back up no the other one
already moved on I only saw the one
before and I forgot one
show the one before that but I forgot
one
ah there's two kings in this poster but
it's not two it's actually code Kings
because you got to be on cocaine to
design a post of this dub next poster
okay okay 4dx yeah that's uh that's
actually not uh wasp striking a pose
that's how her Spine Works after she
watched a movie in 4ds oh the chairs
Rattle and your bones
wow I guess you could say Fame has
really gone to Scott Lang's head in this
world it's huge look at that if you look
close Cassie is wearing what look like
Chucks Chuck Taylor Shoes where did she
get her uh her stature outfit Journeys
oh
[Music]
oh these are the character posters never
mind I'm sorry I didn't realize these
were so cool yeah
wow like more like Scott Payne in the
ass why is this guy keep getting that's
in so many pickles uh more like Scott
pudd yeah
oh
uh he's just a good looking guy yeah
there's another Scarface that's gonna
get blown by Michelle Pfeiffer oh my God
Thomas yo this is the man who spends all
his time researching pin particles to
cure erectile dysfunction I can't get
cancer from going down on people in the
quantum realm right Hank
get back go back as long as we don't
curse in the first 30 seconds we don't
Miss oh so we still got time to curse uh
I I think I saw this guy on January 6th
wait where was Jessica on January 6th
well we have to remember we are the
kings of Queens of Rose County I was
there so we might have been there for
comedic reasons ah why are so many of
these people dressed in cloaks is the
costume designer Stevie Nicks
is this an episode of euphoria that
wasn't even a disc it just looks good
yeah
oh oh she's definitely holding in a [ __ ]
[Music]
she started in a local community
theater's production of Peter Pan with
that haircut whoa I mean from the
ceiling I mean what's Kate Gosling gonna
do with the quantum realm she's got
she's got eight kids she's gonna watch
out John and Kate Plus saying hey let me
ask you something how does how does that
woman expect us to give her a shot in
this movie well she won't get a shot of
her own yeah
looks like quantumania sponsored by heck
up for men
oh yeah what did someone say this looks
like the most Boomer episode of SNL ever
Mike Douglas Mickey Pfeiffer will Murray
Paul rude
anyway
I like his Ray Charles impression in the
back if you can bring the photo back up
it makes more sense there it is quantum
moves differently
that's why Quantum room is on my mind
you know
we had a lot of functions today guys
but at the end of the day we love these
movies and that's why we roast them
you know Ant-Man quantumania Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania you're one of my
best friends we grew up together in the
clubs you know I wouldn't be me without
you and I just want to say I wish you
the best and you're a real good sport
for being up here today oh so
um uh I'm Max
real Ford real 3D screen X
we love you we'd love to see the movies
yeah please send us tickets to any of
your screens to decorate but other than
that awesome uh Doctor Strange poster in
the background send us another poster we
need to decorate this place we can't
just have Horace the Snowman over there
where's the picture of me oh we banned
photos
uh real quick let's shout out
um a couple other folks sitting in super
chats match 143 uh cocaine for the win
um uh Christian unpronounceable our
friend from Canada uh lost wasp oh good
one that's a good pun
um thank you Kiana Chanel Murray in the
mix uh Bill Murray character in Ant-Man
and then wasp
I'm not sure I get that one but
um and then uh Corey kids really
pointing out return of Babu Frick and
that Mandalorian trailer Babu Frick the
only way you're ever going to get me to
give a Baboo
[ __ ] about a Star Wars show again I'm a
roaster I'm not obsessed is that the
Bible one of them V Babu Frick I think
they're all Babu freak they're all
Singularity they have the hive times
we are all freaks
uh thank you so much uh for going off
the rails there with us as we uh take a
dark journey into uh WrestleMania
um and thank you again for everybody in
the chat everybody's sitting in super
chats we'll be back uh we might talk a
little bit more about that my DeLorean
trailer tomorrow we'll see there'll be
some more Mandalorian content coming out
very soon we also there's a very fun uh
segment about uh Agatha Covenant of
chaos yeah that we are working on wasn't
quite ready today it's gonna be really
fun later this week check out that a lot
of great content coming out on the
channel of course uh more content uh
this week about Ant-Man the WASP Quantum
Mania what are some other stuff people
should look forward all right Eric's
breakdown of uh The Last of Us is
already out the breakdown of the
Mandalorian trailer
today uh I also uh Prince Harry's been
releasing some audio excerpts from this
book so uh if you're not sick of that
yeah
what a difficult life I've had having
everything given to me my brother shoved
me once uh we got lots of Ant-Man
content this week or some more
Mandalorian content from Tommy uh
awesome stuff on the channel Prince
Harry come on the show hey come on the
show and bring simulu with you that's
right we'll only let you in if you bring
in CMU please uh thank you so much for
watching thank you to nordvpn Again
download VPN so you can watch knives out
and chat about it with us on Friday uh
thank you all so much for watching have
a great rest of your day thanks
[Music]